agora o pulso ao bndes a mais em vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer as garras do
alvarinho usando folhas a4 de impressora
por ter usado impressora mas vocês podem
usar outras folhas quaisquer e que estou
eu a fazer cara de pau a tentar mas o
produto não ficou se ficou um caso
estranho sair do zero sobre esta prova é
um moleque solo e mãe do mundo bravo
folha vai encarar bem
dobre pra linha do centro quase deixando
que a distância entre a linha do centro
que a folha
dobre em para a linha em cada vem mais
duas voltas
agora faça o mesmo para o outro lado
escusado dizer que você não tem que
fazer três lâminas por cada garrafa que
vocês quiserem fazer até agora vamos
fazer um tempo para tanto um lado e do
outro em caruaru em dobrar para a linha
do centro mais uma vez feito isso a
abrir cortar na segunda linha
feito isso vou juntar tudo e vão prender
usando fita como fazer uma fita
transparente para não citar um toque
escolar em vão ter que tirar a ponta só
pra não ficar perigoso toque de bola e
uma folha como se fosse uma rifa daquela
das feiras empreendam com fita para não
se surpreender
vão rolar assim na ponta uma das pontas
da fifa vai ter um fim dos votos de
todos os votos deles foi muito grande
vou ter que enrolar mais forem mais que
não vou precisar usar tanto aqui e se
vocês pois a justa
não tenho um pouquinho com o outro
agora só falta juntar o outro vai ter lá
minas e depois juntar mais potente só
colocarem os pontinhos dentro das
lâminas de atenção nesta parte que vão
aprender assim com fita vai de um lado
certo
o pessoal agora só agarrar empurrar as
lâminas para se ajustar bem a vossa mão
e propôs aos cabos ou fios perdão
estados vocês gostaram mesmo negócio aí
eu posso ir e se inscrevam no canal que
estuda ajuda bastante a divulgação e
evolução do meu trabalho cluster mais
sugestões por jet ski foi uma sugestão
vossa é só deixar nos comentários que o
faça né e um grande abraço e até à
próxima champions e é fã porque foi essa